Yo todavía estaba allí.
Realmente creo que el cine nos enseña a ver.
La forma de mostrar el mundo
va a cambiar la forma que vemos este mundo
y vivimos en un momento en el que los medios masivos
están haciendo un trabajo terrible
al representar el mundo:
violencia, extremistas,
solo eventos espectaculares,
solo simplificaciones de la vida cotidiana.
Creo que estamos grabando
para recuperar una cierta complejidad.
Para reinventar la vida de hoy,
tenemos que hacer nuevas formas de imágenes.
Y es muy simple.
Muito obrigado.
(Aplausos)
Bruno Giussani: Vicente, Vicente, Vicente.
Merci. Tenemos que prepararnos para la siguiente actuación,
y quiero preguntarte algo y es lo siguiente:
Te apareces en lugares como los que nos ha mostrado,
y llevas una cámara
y supongo que eres bienvenido
pero seguro que no siempre eres totalmente bienvenido.
Entras en rituales sagrados,
en momentos privados en un pueblo, una ciudad,
en un grupo de personas.
¿Cómo rompes la barrera
cuando te presentas con una cámara?
VM: Creo que la rompes con tu cuerpo,
más que con el conocimiento.
Eso es lo que me enseñó viajar,
a confiar en la memoria del cuerpo
más que en la memoria del cerebro.
El respeto es un paso adelante,
no ir hacia atrás, y realmente creo que
mediante la participación del cuerpo en el momento, en la ceremonia,
en los lugares, las personas te dan la bienvenida
y entienden tu energía.
BG: Me dijiste que la mayoría de los vídeos
que haces son en realidad de una sola toma.
Que no haces mucha edición.
Es decir, las editaste para nosotros
al inicio de las sesiones por su longitud, etc.
De otra manera, solo tienes que entrar y filmar
lo que pase ante tus ojos
sin mucha planificación, ¿es así?
¿Es correcto?
VM: Mi idea es que
mientras no cortemos, de una manera,
siempre y cuando dejamos que el espectador lo vea,
más y más espectadores se van a sentir más cerca,
van a estar más cerca del momento,
para ese momento y ese lugar.
Realmente creo que es una forma de respetar al espectador,
no cortar todo el tiempo de un lugar a otro,
y dejar que el tiempo pase.
BG: Dime en pocas palabras algo de tu nuevo proyecto,
"Híbridos", aquí en Brasil.
Justo antes de venir a TEDGlobal, tú en realidad
estuviste viajando por todo el país para eso.
Cuéntanos un par de cosas.
VM: "Híbridos" es... realmente creo que Brasil,
lejos de los clichés, es el país religioso más grande del mundo,
el país más grande en términos de espiritualidad
y en experimentos espirituales.
Y es un gran proyecto que estoy haciendo este año,
en que estoy investigando en diferentes regiones de Brasil,
en muy diferentes formas de cultos,
y tratando de entender cómo la gente vive junto
con la espiritualidad hoy en día.
BG: El hombre que va a aparecer en el escenario en un momento,
y Vincent lo va a presentar,
es uno de los temas de uno de sus vídeos anteriores.
¿Cuándo hiciste un video con él?
VM: Creo que hace cuatro años,
cuatro años en mi primer viaje.
BG: Así que fue uno de los primeros en Brasil.
VM: Fue de los primeros en Brasil, sí.
Realicé la película en Recife,
en el lugar de dónde es.
BG: Así que vamos a presentarle. ¿A quién estamos esperando?
VM: Lo haré muy corto.
Es un gran honor dar la bienvenida en el escenario
a uno de los más grandes músicos brasileños de todos los tiempos.
Démosle la bienvenida a Naná Vasconcelos.
BG: ¡Naná Vasconcelos!
(Aplausos)
(Música)
Naná Vasconcelos: Vayamos a la selva.
(Aplausos)